true news is sponsored by surf shark
which is why he's using his phone on
surf shop we're using this on surf shark
if you want to do the same sign up in
the link in the description surf shark
is fantastic it can take you anywhere in
the world it's a great price and it's
probably something that you actually
need if you're on the internet
especially in these times where some
people will be targeting your identity
online there are people out there that
want to hack you there are people out
there that want to get into your amazon
your little instagram account i've had
plenty of people messaging me on a
weekly basis they've been hacked
horrible horrible horrible keep your
identity private online but not only
that if you want to get the american
netflix they say everything's better in
america head over there with serve shark
boom you've got the whole american
netflix to look at you're welcome you
could be a memphis could be anything
walk
should i do the deal but yeah do the
deal bit 83 off whoa with three months
extra for free unbelievable
and a 30-day money-back guarantee so if
you aren't happy with it sure serve
shark is just giving your money back but
whatever you go have it back but you
won't you know why because nobody ever
does because it's so damn good so good
go and take a look at surf shark right
now there's a link down there in the
description use code geordie and you'll
get all of that offer as one bundle let
us know what you think but for now it's
true news
[Music]
if i was to get back in the ring as a
warm-up fight just to get you know get
rid of the cobwebs i i
fight alexis i'll be [__] let me just
go in [__]
[Music]
cookies
youtube boxing is unfortunately back oh
i'm so sorry it was a new law for
youtube boxing and that really says
something there was a lot of build up to
this fight of course deji felt very
confident or at least he looked like he
was very confident this is two defeats
in her own now for denji don't ever
bother don't ever box again until you
work in your car and this one was worse
than the jig i really feel like
everything i'm about to say could just
be gonna get clipped up again just
changed two defeats in a three well
this
you know if you're the director i get it
this is beautifully shot really nicely
done you get him to go look a bit meaner
down the lens you don't go can you look
sort of nervous and constipated for me
on camera yeah you've nailed it mate
because i know daddy's mentality he
wants to prove
the world wrong he wants to prove the
world wrong of course the whole world
was saying he can't possibly get any
worse well
he proved the world wrong is it bad to
pile in on deji it isn't bad when you
charge so much money to watch a
pay-per-view on the basis that you're
going to turn up and be better than
before and you've had months and months
to train for this this is fair we're not
seeing he's a bad person not man i'm
saying we hate the guy no we're saying
he chatted absolute [__] i did feel a
bit cheated on the night if i didn't
because i knew the whole time and i told
everyone yes alex was didn't i i said
alex wassabi's winning this fight yeah
because when someone's shown you who
they are two times you gotta start
believing them for me once shame on
absolutely for me three times you ain't
gonna fool me again boy
what does this do what's happening with
the water because you don't sweat in
droplets like that is that water looks
yeah over his own head they did that on
me on the gym shark shoot once they give
me a bit of a spray and i'm like to be
honest i just sort of sweat anyway
really yeah exactly
yeah just let me do two press-ups
whoever edited that you deserve a medal
you literally or the reason so many
people parted with their money and the
belief that dead you might turn up
you're the biggest liar of them all well
absolutely do you want a job yeah we are
hiring genuinely i mean if you can make
deji look like a boxer what can you make
me look like a boxer
that'll do yeah who am i fighting next
deji's taking so many punches he now has
early onset dementia
genuinely right not bad at all that
where was that in the fight edge mainly
because you're literally
but in the fight the little pretty boy
was chasing you down as you basically
ran away from him what the [__] happened
there this kid took shots from jake paul
who is probably the hardest hitter in
the youtube boxing thing when at adi
with vinnie hakka took plenty of digs
off of him kept going and yet against
alex he didn't want it after all the
chat that's what i'm frustrated i don't
really losing is one thing but not even
giving 100 when all these people have to
pay to see you and all these people have
turned up to support you i think that's
why jj made this video about how
frustrated he was is because he didn't
even go out on your shield like there's
there is ability there but [__] hell
hey what's up guys it's deji he filmed
this the day after the fight looks like
he didn't even leave the house last
night but that's it like he barely took
any real damage and i get that that's
like but it's hit and don't get hit
right not don't get hit unfortunately
i lost my last boxing fight and i said
that if i were to lose
my last boxing fight i'd never fight
again and i was serious about that good
he was serious no more boxing just cut
the video down
done 15 seconds we're out the thing is
before i even carry on i love boxing oh
dude boxing doesn't love you dodgy my
current coach right now is daily the
daily effect i only got to
experience daily for for six weeks and
it was barely even six weeks because the
first week was just me in like getting
to know him get to know what we didn't
go for dinner listen we're just getting
to know each other here what's your star
sign yeah i'm not a punch on the first
session sort of guy we should go on at
least three sessions before you and i
can move forward with this whoa there i
see you putting on some pads in those
three weeks with daley he's not only
just matured me as a person but he's
made me a better boxer already in three
weeks he's not just like a mentor to me
he's literally like a brother i'm not
saying he can't like the guy after three
weeks i'm sure he's a lovely guy great
coach i'm sure it's all good got to know
each other a brother he rushes into this
stuff if i'm his actual brother i'm like
what the [__] is this like to be fair
there is no much [__] i've put up with
having to carry your sorry ass on
youtube for the last [__] five to ten
years to be fair maybe you're telling me
this guy you've met for three weeks is
like a brother to you maybe that's what
it is
maybe daley maybe daley went listen i
also won't join you for christmas and he
went absolutely you're like a brother to
me you want to come over for christmas
you went absolutely not he went you are
just like jj oh my god so with all that
being said am i gonna box again
or am i gonna
hang up the towel throw in the towel
hung up the gloves the gloves yeah
whatever what i do is i've thrown in the
gloves and i [__] up the towel goodbye
boxing i watched the fight back and yeah
i look sick if you were to watch that
you could you can't even be like that's
a terrible effort i don't mean this in a
nasty way for that you but like it was a
terrible effort like he's giving himself
credit for slipping punches but that's
so much easier to do when you're not
throwing punches right when all you're
thinking about is defense defense
defense it's a lot easier to get out the
way back off run away dip your head
loose
because you're not actually committing
and taking the risk of hitting the other
guy which then leaves you open to be
punched you never hear an armadillo go
won that one even against vinnie hatta
when you were tired and fat and all of
that you went out there and threw and
actually tried to win the fight you
didn't even try to win this fight and
people who know boxing know that's facts
if our performance was lackluster and
terrible yesterday i would not have the
support i'm having right now people are
just giving him credit cause he lost a
bit of [__] weight exactly people did
not pay that money what was it 9.99 we
paid on the right to see you come out
looking a bit slimmer i want to pay 9.99
a month to see people look slimmer i'll
join weight watchers all right i love
watching louise on a thursday no i just
i just went weight watchers over there
not because you're fat
i've seen that yeah
note it then you guys had to show me
that i've evolved because i didn't even
realize i was going through my instagram
dms you guys are the real ones is uh
freddie roach in those dm's you were all
telling me don't quit i see this as part
of my legacy i don't want to be someone
who quits you know what the sad thing is
is he's saying just want to be seen to
be someone who quits let's be real like
he quit in the vinnie hackney fight he
didn't even get to a point where he
needed to quit in this fight because he
never actually put himself out there to
be that badly hurt he didn't actually
give anywhere near his all in this fight
right again so i wanted him to prove us
wrong i wanted deji to come out of his
brother's shadow and to prove that he is
more than just a guy who's dined out on
his brother's talent but i want to i
want you to see me as an example yeah i
failed three times but i'm i'm not
stopping i'm coming back what i'm doing
is i'm ignoring all the signs and
signals that i should stop down this
route let me be an example to you and
i'm gonna get a victory and you know for
a fact i will there's no credibility in
that now you've literally fought
multiple people in their first ever
fight while you were gaining an
experience and still couldn't be any of
them no offense but there was a lot of
creators who came up with massive
support for deji after this fight and i
just feel like sometimes you got to be
honest with people with three fights in
now against you know not very athletic
people they're very happy yeah sure
outside of jake paul the other two guys
very beatable that being said yes i'm
gonna carry on boxing i'm not gonna quit
i know a lot of you were happy with me
saying that and a lot of you were pissed
being like retired but but i want to be
an example for people daddy's brother
ksi also made a video about the fight
here it is see my brother uh fight as
well against alex that guy part of the
interest from this is that jj has never
liked alex wassabi having his brother
lose to another one of his enemies you
must he keeps giving his enemies a win
over him in a way yeah because
you come up and you go dead you're sure
you're going to win this one i'm going
to turn up to your fight i'm going to be
there i'll be supportive of you and then
your piss is boiling because your
brother just went sores about that yeah
so let me talk about the event uh the
event was entertaining but a mess at the
same time first of all the guy who did
the racist rant it was just the worst
and it wasn't just that man we had like
just really bad boxing throughout the
night uh but i mean that's kind of what
we love about youtube boxing but some of
it was just like i mean someone nutted
someone in the head yeah if i want to
see someone not on someone else i'll i
know where i'm going i mean ryan taylor
headbutted dk money and got disqualified
uh rightly so but for some reason dk
money wasn't announced as the winner the
funny thing is is that dk money fella he
kind of seemed to take a dive he went
down like in a delayed reaction like a
premier league footballer was i kind of
don't know if this is genius or just
mental of course it's genius he still
gets the money and he doesn't have to
fight vitaly got head-butted three times
christian even admitted
after the fight that he head-butted
vitale there it is there's the thing
that everyone went there for you know
what you were going to talk about david
lauca's scarf this scoff stole the show
the longest thing i've ever seen some
women get married you know their wedding
dress is supposed to be really long down
the aisle david like a scarf longer it
actually kept growing throughout the
night as well i actually felt like he'd
go sort of ringside and his grandma
would keep knitting for yeah yeah yeah
vitaly there um not long ago seemed to
jump on a woman and beat the crap out of
her in broad daylight videoed probably a
prank brian and yeah still makes it into
the country i'd probably a prank what a
weird stuff and you're looking at him
thinking he's a big guy yeah the guy
punches like a girl i don't even think
he punches like a girl that's not a
woman sorry i do apologize but you know
he punches like a slap he's yeah it was
just it was just bad don't be angry
brian we get another great view of dave
wow that's scarf growing oh my god
there's a lot that went wrong and very
little that went right it made me
realize i just i don't know if i ever
want to do anything like that again when
we started like it was bad production
there was elements of it that were bad
but like the fights were good people
took it seriously yeah at the time it
was good good spirit it's just [__]
shocking you can actually feel like the
bad vibes coming through the screen
literally i think joella who was
commenting at one point was talking
about like getting up and leaving or
something like it was an embarrassment
that show uh deji i'm i'm disappointed
that's honestly how i feel man like how
are you going to win a fight against a
taller a taller fighter on the outside
that's you just stayed on the outside
range you rarely went in and then
whenever you did go in you would just
ruin all your hard work
by holding when it comes to fighting a
taller fire you have to take one punch
to give two that's just it that's just
what you have to deal with you have to
slip inside to to get in range you have
to outwork him where was he overhand
where was where was the body work where
were the hooks absolutely spot on i know
a few people thought that jj is being
harsh here you don't know boxing maybe
he shouldn't be doing this in public
whatever like deji and jj have always
had a public relationship they've always
been like that and this needs to be said
because dead she's putting out videos
that are completely delusional someone
needs to hold them accountable in public
he's giving him bang on advice here you
literally did nothing but avoid punches
like do you did you actually think you
would win by just doing that i think he
did like judging by his own video i
looked so cool [__] hell is this guy
like being taught it's funny because
deji probably goes into his first
session after and daley genuinely goes
you're awful he goes like a brother to
me
i just don't understand how you gonna
lose your redemption fight to alex
wassabi man this guy is literally
a child in a grown man's body does he
find an actual child next what about
that fella from russia the little one oh
i'm
hezbollah just sort of hold him it's not
going to work he'll probably get on the
inside and out working did she tell me
how are you going to lose weight
get fitter and still throw less punches
than you did when you were fat dead you
will fight again though so we all look
forward to that and sure we'll all be
live streaming do you know the one fight
the one fight i would watch from deji it
would be joe weller that is redemption
meets redemption speaking of famous
siblings uh kim kardashian has given us
all some great advice get your [__]
ass up and work it seems like nobody
wants to work these days you [__]
when they pan out and she's like full in
leather yeah like all dolled up in
makeup and and doing her work you know
when you talk about work you talk about
having work done because you've had a
[__] ton absolutely get all that work
done you know nobody wants to work these
days you have to so true what i love is
all the other sisters
that's so true
you have to surround yourself with
people
that want to work
have a good work environment where
everyone loves what they do because you
have one life no toxic work environments
and show up and do the work you know
when she's saying show up and do the
work she's using the most broad term
because she's like i have no [__]
clue what regular people do for work
like imagine her going into um like
amazon delivery service yeah and giving
that speech out can you guys all just do
some [__] quick please talk soon you
guys are [__] working [__] work
love what you do when you put that box
over there i want you to love it you're
in a dead-end job you better love it i
am not saying that you know kim
kardashian doesn't have a work ethic of
some sort but she lives a life of luxury
where she can pick and choose only the
things she enjoys and then throws
herself into them from fashion modeling
criminal law and all the other stuff
that she's been involved in in her life
she is so privileged this sort of molly
may kim advice a [__] that they keep
coming out with where you just say how
removed from reality you get to take
pictures for your instagram all day
that's that's that's your life yeah you
understand the rest of us nah not a
[__] chance from the start we decided
that we always wanted to be really open
and honest to who we are so open and
honest by the way that they edited uh
what was days and days of their lives
down to half hour episodes when we would
film tough episodes that were really
about our life whether it was breakups
or multiple producers come out of your
show and said that you constantly misled
people on what actually happened on set
they said you treated yourself terribly
and that very often your expectations of
production were wildly unethical and as
long as i say i'm authentic therefore i
am authentic breakups or
transitions or things that other people
might be having a hard time dealing with
at home i know i can really relate you
know when my dad transitioned into a
woman it made me much easier for me that
they've been through that absolutely so
yeah dad sorry i mean mom we're here for
you we're all here for you we're all
here for you michelle if that changed
the way that reality tv is you know
viewed or seen as being really helpful
and informational i think that makes me
proud no one ever watches reality tv
rupaul's drugs yeah i think to myself
these queens the only thing you're
learning is how to put makeup on i want
to say
absolutely she is just looking so real
she's just so natural she's so real in
the way she puts she's literally having
[__] sucked out of her belly and
injected into her ass that's why her
legs are skinny and her ass cheeks are
big do you know do you know many women
with big arses have tiny little
matchstick legs like that none of them
none of them yeah unless they've had
this done absolutely i'm not saying you
shouldn't get surgery no but this woman
has lied and lied and lied about what
she's had done for over a decade and i
think something that we've always stayed
true to is that we want to film really
what we're going through let's hear from
khloe kardashian but someone who
literally sees things in the press so
that you don't hear the bad news about
her here's the mad thing about this
caitlyn jenner is the realest one of all
these people she's the only one actually
living the truth the truth and by the
way also the only one with any [__]
real talent right the woman at the time
won a [__] decathlon yeah do you know
how hard that is do you know what that's
not [__]
10 events yeah i watched a documentary
about this person yeah and i was like
wow wow that's unbelievable so do you
know what happened to that man at the
time turned woman later they [__]
ruined him and i'm not seeing ruined him
by turning him into a woman right i mean
you can see this strong champion just
wither away in the same way we've seen
up in the canyon if i'm being honest
these people aren't good what's
important to remember is we've been able
to shine a really bright light on issues
like the homeless situation in los
angeles she is pure evil she's she's the
worst of the world
if we were talking disney characters
she'd be the octopus woman in the little
mermaid i think we've learned a good
balance of boundaries over the years
starting to get me started on boundaries
queen of boundaries we've all had
boundaries down the years my boundary
stops at releasing a sex tape in public
and letting you all watch it so i got
famous i think i definitely started the
boundaries conversation but i think it's
like boundaries within
even like how to balance like filming
and then she literally is just
describing what a boundary is that
drummer fella who's with her it's a good
job he's hard of hearing that's just
knowing that like we need to work out in
the morning before we kind of start our
day like all the things to survive she's
a trailblazer she's a trailblazer
we need to work out in the morning she
is a trailblazer you know what i mean
this woman might eat breakfast before 12
a.m she's blazing a trail uh other women
are pretending to be things that they
aren't for a lot of money and it turns
out that men will pay you a lot of money
if they can then toss off over whatever
content it is that you make i wish that
men masturbated to our content seriously
let me know if you do there's one or two
say you're of age right now and like you
know perfectly legal i'm going to
encourage you just to pull your [__] out
give a little stroke go on will it help
if i touched him what if i did that big
man you must have had a long day you're
a giant well it turns out that this
woman makes a lot of money from
pretending to be a giant i actually do
feel like i've missed the trick here do
you know what i'm saying you don't need
to be like out of me and this five foot
five girl or whatever she is yeah she's
the one making money off of being a
giant right no but you're the yeah
you're the dumb [__] because you didn't
pick i really am a giant yeah exactly
she said she has been asked for all
sorts of things from pictures of her
feet to eating videos and to pretend to
be a giant i've had invites to people's
weddings which is a bit strange that is
a bit weird because basically when you
turn up to that wedding that man then
goes oh i toss off over you so there is
like a giant fetish online that you know
that people are basically they want to
see a big woman's vagina or a big
woman's boobs and they think that would
be like sex okay so that is purely what
she gets asked for no she gets lots of
[__] she's just a normal only fans girl
basically correct a lot of money yeah
exactly one of them is her pretend to be
a giant and they've used a picture where
and here she is being a giant it's like
no she's just in her bedroom she's
literally yeah she's just like another
one yeah i don't know whether she like
buys little cars and stuff and then sort
of picks them up and eats them or like
does something with it this woman is
like a modern-day myth how do you
pretend to be a giant you basically just
put lots of small things around you and
i imagine you know like these only fans
they do like individual videos for
people that sort of thing so they'll go
yeah i hear that your sex fetish is
giant so i've made myself huge and now
i'm huge in this video and then the man
sort of you know knocks one out to it
for ages and all these other guys go
well if he finds it sexy i might too
here we go wow i might become an only
fans girl maybe just hold that thought
because there's a new article creepy
stalker lived in only fans model attic
and came out at night to film her he
acquired her keys and made identical
versions which meant he could enter the
property whenever he wanted can i just
say the details in the article are
[__] incredible you know if he hadn't
have made an identical version of her
key the key wouldn't have worked so
basically she'd go to sleep oblivious
and uh this little piggy would come out
of uh the attic oh my god beat off to
her naked body as she slept all i'm
saying is you're more likely to
encounter weird [__] by being on only
fans than if you worked in a library i'm
not saying you shouldn't do only fans
but it is a bit more risky the guy first
claimed to have broken into the home to
retrieve a tv and fireplace he bought as
a present this is the problem man when
you've got amazon wishlists right you
are letting fricks online buy [__] for
you that makes you weird too i like to
know where my money comes from and
that's what happens where men like this
start to feel ownership
yeah he starts to feel like well i got
you this therefore i might just take her
back oh i know i'm going to want to know
where she lives now any excuse he's a
nutter he claimed the only fans model
wanted a man to be obsessed with her and
stalk her right part of being in that
online world is you need your regulars
you need money to keep coming in you
need to develop somewhat relationships
with these people who are watching you
on a daily basis how else does the
business model work you need someone
who's a bit fascinated by you to keep
coming back to keep paying the money
because it's a monthly subscription
service i'm not saying that makes it all
right for
someone to stalk someone i'm saying the
likelihood of it happening is higher
than if you do a normal job and if
you're ignorant of that in the words of
kim kardashian welcome to the real world
she had [__] stalkers do you know
what i mean former ufc heavyweight
champion of the world k in velasquez has
been arrested on attempted murder this
is a guy who is a bit of a hero to me to
be honest one of my favorite fighters of
all time a bad [__] but a good
[__] pretty much a clean
criminal record and you know upstanding
family man and out of nowhere i'm like
attempted murder cain velasquez this
didn't fit it didn't add up and it turns
out some sick piece of [__] was
allegedly abusing his daughter at play
school you know the girl's like four
years old and not just his daughter
other children there the pedophile was
arrested and then bailed because
apparently he wasn't a danger of the
public a man who allegedly sexually
abused this child over 100 times was
allowed bail then let that sink in and
think about her dad was one of the
toughest men ever to walk this earth
right a man who beat the living [__] out
of brock lesnar in one round so cain
velasquez does what any man with a set
of balls would do when he went looking
for him found him on a highway driving
after him the guy's dad was driving him
away from came velasquez in the getaway
car came velasquez opens fire lands a
bullet in the dad and unfortunately
didn't kill
the pedophile and now king velazquez is
in prison and not being allowed bail and
potentially doing 10 to 15 years for
what i think is like a temporary
insanity thing you know you found that
your child the person you love more than
there's anything else in this world is
being abused and you want to kill that
[__] and yet you'll probably do
more time than he will that's how [__]
this world is i know like legally we
can't advocate vigilantism but at the
same time there has to be common sense
in the law at some point the guy's
daughter was abused and and he went
looking for you've got to take into
account the fact that his criminal
record was exemplary beforehand to treat
him worse than the original offender
when what he did to me is the worst
sickest thing in this world it's
staggering where we are and it i feel
like really bad about this like i'm
looking at cain velasquez right this is
a man who to me is a hero like he wanted
to defend his daughter he knew the risks
he knew i'm going to prison and i'm
going to kill him anyway do you
understand how where his head was at
like there's crimes of passion there's
there's temporary insanity like surely
they have to be lenient with this guy
this is [__] heartbreak and this is a
hall of fame athlete here this isn't i
know he's a fighter he's a ufc guy and
people think they're animals this is a
really good dude he fought for a living
but the guy was like an amateur wrestler
before then high school all-star athlete
like a good uh community guy you're like
this really [__] me up because i think
any man out there with a set of [__]
balls on them would probably do the same
thing you know it's like like lock us
all up then do you know what i mean
because it's outrageous that he's going
to do more time in prison than the guy
who's the actual offender here who's the
real piece of [__] yeah that's where i
think the justice system needs to be
looked at isn't it because yeah this guy
really has ruined someone's life yeah
cain velasquez
victim here in a sense because he wasn't
just sitting there watching tv and
thought oh no i'm just gonna go and
shoot some [__] there was cause here
this was provoked heavily provoked in
the worst way possible this man is lucky
cain didn't get his hands on him because
it would have been worse than a bullet
in the head as [__] some of you remember
we do a lot of food reviewers down the
years i'll be honest i never i've never
heard of this guy he's really famous
nicardo avocado he started doing
mukbangs when he was younger and was
very in shape and over the years he's
slowly become less and less and less in
shape can i say one from when he first
started just so i've got context before
i see him not a bad looking guy i'd say
he looks about your build in terms of
like um slenderness sure he's quite
slender yeah in terms of like your body
fat he looks about similar similar to
that right whoa that's him now is that
the same guy with it i haven't made a
video for about one week now and i have
my reasons for that so he comes across
as quite like a mild mannered quite a
chill guy there
oh
spaghetti girls
i just got back from the doctors i have
a doctor lady what's really weird is
he's gone the other way yeah most
youtubers start off really [__]
annoying and eventually they're like
calm down i'm a human yeah he was
actually pretty chill before i don't
know why he's putting this act on but
it's it's weird i walked in i sat on the
chair and i sit down on the chair and
the chair goes
earthquake she says you're too big for
the shirt
excuse me lady so anyway he has like
these little monologues at the start of
the video which are basically as far as
i can work out they seem like some sort
of fetish based stuff where it's kind of
basically him going i've been shamed for
my weight after that he then does this
[Music]
what are we watching hi everyone
hey
now this is the main video is she has
mother awesome no she's just a friend of
me
i'm here with hungry fat chick
now if you call your kid hungry fat
chick there's only one way they're going
today we're going to be weighing
ourselves on camera yes they're going to
weigh themselves i'm fascinated to know
what they weigh by the way i'm morbidly
fascinated as much as he's morbidly
obese i like bigger women right i think
i've been quite open and honest about
that that's fine i like thick women yeah
when you hit a certain point though and
it becomes really unhealthy that's why i
feel uncomfortable not in a judgmental
way like you know i've seen we've all
seen plenty of fat people at this point
like it's more just in a like you're
gonna regret this on your hospital bed
kind of way where it's like and i i feel
the same way by the way when i see
someone who's abnormally skinny and they
look like they're struggling on a mental
health level
i look at them in the same exact way i
think dangerous worrying like i'm hardly
the best [__] picture of health ever
but it freaks me out a bit i'm like i
literally i'm watching someone dying in
front of me right now right it [__] it
freaks me out this a bit and we have
some party supplies ready because
we might be hitting official milestone
yep official milestone do they mean like
they're trying to lose weight or
something no they're trying to gain
weight gain what
okay
short arms y'all draper in this
oh the queen has arrived
i like her laugh i'll give her that yeah
very attractive laughs right
do you know what i mean yeah so we're
having a celebration because i might
finally hit a special milestone you can
see your dick again which is wanna tell
them the number
uh
350 pounds y'all
he actually looks unhappy and like
unhealthy in his face do you know what i
mean as someone who's like i struggled
with my weight you know yeah for years
and i'm trying to get down i could be
350 in about a month like give me a
month of just not running at all i'll be
350. so for him to like celebrate this
it's like weird for me i'm like i'm
trying so hard to get my weight out and
you've got this guy eating up being like
i just got to keep eating i just got to
keep going i'm like i'm kind of jealous
on one hand right like i know how
horrible my body is built to carry
weight his really isn't i remember
currying 350 and thinking [__] me i feel
it feel heavy as [__] it's not good he
must feel terrible i feel like he gets
some sort of sexual do you think men
like because i feel like he's probably
gay yes he's um yeah he used to have a
partner he used to eat with i just
wonder if there's men out there who
prefer cuddly teddy bear guy maybe
that's part of it you know yeah there's
like an almost feminine quality to him
where he's got like boobs and sort of
quite he's quite round anyway they're
about to weigh themselves on some scales
that can speak
oh my god watching her stand up bro i
feel [__] terrible for her yeah like
for regular people who can just stand up
out of their bed
and it's not a problem we all just take
that for granted this woman just stood
up as if she was squatting and it's
because she is she's squatting however
many pounds she and her body is not
built for that she could be half her
weight and still be overweight
look at that just a step in front of the
one this this reminds me of um strong
man you know when they do the farm as
walk and they carry all of that and just
putting one foot in front of the other
is a workout do you know how easy it
would be for her to lose weight though
like literally just do a little bit of
walking drop one less pizza a day to
carry that kind of weight she must be
taking on so many many calories just to
keep that weight up even just while
lying in your bed you have to eat so
much this is an effort like that's
probably why they're celebrating
her belly it's gone beyond being a belly
and it's now just like it's another body
part
it's just like a growth isn't it it's
the artist formerly known as her belly
exactly it's become another human it's
just a symbol honestly i get that this
is there is a very obvious reason why
she is this weight and i bet there are a
lot of men that pay a lot of money to
watch this woman i i guarantee that's
part of it like you can tell just
looking at her she probably gets naked
on the webcam and men are like
yeah men are like yeah you love it
you're trapped in your bed and i'm your
master
right yeah
453 4.2
hundred and fifty thrones do you
remember the big show in the wrestling
he was that yeah he was seven foot he
was the man he was built fashion he was
like massive he was a giant he was a
literal giant oh my
goodness
i am so proud of you
and then we're in this little support
group which is sort of quite a toxic
kind of like this is not healthy like
that's like literally right you've got
an alcoholic who's on the brink of death
and you're like clapping them i'm so
proud of you like you're that's not a
good friend that like no that's [__]
insane and now they're gonna eat bowls
and bowls and bowls of hot hot noodles
oh
yep cheese is on the bottom oh i see it
i wish i could feel this level of
happiness
about anything in my day
she's starving
okay darvin marvin you're a lot of
things pet starving is not one of them
you know when you're bigger though do
you get hungry quicker obviously because
your body sort of constantly
yeah that's the diabetes
it's literally her blood sugar levels
dropping because she's so used to just
intense calories do you think she has
diabetes she almost definitely has yeah
100 but like what we're talking about
someone who has probably in the region
of 15 000 calories per day are we the
only ones wondering about what comes
later because she's eating the hottest
thing possible yeah her ass cheeks are
going to be almost glued shut like how
is this functioning does she have a
helper like how does she spread her
cheeks in order to even go do you know
how people are back scratchers right she
must have some sort of like thing yeah
which sort of goes you know like
japanese toilets
she's probably just got some
sorry do these two actually make it
through these
holy [__] oh my god her body is now
accustomed to so many calories like she
can just eat and eat and eat she's
almost like an athlete in a weird way
right yeah can we look at her wishlist
though she does because i think this is
fascinating self-therapeutic bamboo back
scratcher i might actually add that to
my car yeah that's a real good show
though and it's your wishlist yeah just
let us know in the comments and then
this will be a good way of finding out
if you watch to the end if i had an
amazon wishlist would you buy me stuff
i'm not saying i'm gonna i'm just more
interested well there's a seven and a
half inch uh resin skull with astrology
engravings your astrology says you went
res in school with that i was worried it
was going to be something else although
with the size of her you do think what
kind of man would actually be able to
reach the [__] g-spot you've got a
lot of [__] cheeks to get through
right like there's a lot of caution
before you can even get to the [__]
entry point i want to see if she's done
like the um the nerdy stuff and that
yeah that's yeah she's done it yeah
she's done it all right she's done it
all at some point though the belly gets
i was kind of hoping she was just in it
for the food yeah but let's see what
she's doing for the [__] as well wow
really you've clicked the first thing
that popped up there haven't you the
good thing is she's still sitting on the
couch so she's remained loyal to sort of
the way she eats everything she'll still
eat that
don't need to see that and i know what
you're going to try and do so not for me
i'm good
thank you i'm good don't need to look at
that so am i wrong here right i just
wanted to say this one does she suck a
dick it's the same way she eats food
absolutely it looks exactly the same
she's now you wouldn't even notice the
difference really that's true news today
turns out there are fat people in the
world while there's war going on is that
moral or just let us know in the
comments
forget that like below subscribe for
more true news thanks for watching
and we'll see you on the next one